l'association pour la libération des
ondes là l eau les défenseurs donc des
radios libres n'y sont pas allés de main
morte cet après-midi répondantes à
monsieur georges fillioud qui dans le
journal du dimanche s'opposait à nouveau
à toute publicité sur les antennes des
radios privées locales la lots parle de
gifles à l'esprit du 10 mai selon cette
association
la position défendue par le ministre de
la communication équivaut à condamner à
la peine de mort
toutes les radios libres sérieuse et
indépendante c'est du cinquième étage
d'un immeuble du 9e arrondissement
qu'aimer radio pomme cette petite radio
n'ont pas pirates car le terme n'existe
plus depuis le 10 mai est ce qu'on
appelle une radio libre car bien que
toujours interdite par la loi de 1974 et
les toléré par le nouveau gouvernement
socialiste et cela jusqu'à l'adoption
d'un nouveau projet de loi qui aura lieu
à l'assemblée la semaine prochaine salle
de montage rudimentaire studio avec un
joke et deux animatrices qui sont bien
entendu tous bénévoles plus loin une
petite cuisine à côté des carottes et
des condiments l'émetteur relié à
l'antenne sur le toit les 55 bénévoles
techniciens journalistes et animateurs
n'ont peur que d'une chose c'est que
georges fillioud reste sur ses positions
sur l'interdiction des publicités sur
les radios lieux
pour faire une radio de qualité il faut
d'habib is it est évidemment si la
publicité est interdite
il existera toujours des radios libres
mais des radios qui sont qui seront à
faible budget qui seront une
intéressante car pour préparer une heure
d'émission
il faut à peu près comptait 45 heures de
préparation entre le ministre et ce
jeune homme pas d'accord sur la
publicité
mais il ya plus important qu'est ce donc
une radio libre pour le gouvernement à
l'évidence quelque chose qui n'existait
pas et qu'il faudra concrètement inventé
par la loi pour beaucoup de ceux qui se
sont lancés dans l'aventuré
c'est un rêve qui est devenu réalité ne
sera plus un rêve